as the temperature rises in southern
Spain seville's Annual Festival is in
full swing
around half a million people have
converged on this baking City
in a celebration of a region that is
well used to the Heat
but it is far too early in the year for
these kind of conditions
repeat in the middle of the day not at
all I mean I no you cannot you have to
be at home and then go outside on eight
nine in the evening do you worry about
Seville getting hotter I mean I do
because I
mean worry about the the climate change
things are getting even worse
[Music]
away from the festival tourists try to
stay cool
it was exhausting yesterday wasn't it on
the golf course this group of friends
found it too much would you come back to
a city like severe law to Andalucia or
even in the height of Summer knowing
that these temperatures are possible no
I think in a word I think you've got to
pick your time haven't you because it's
hard to you want to walk about and enjoy
everything in the city don't you and
it's how to do that in the summertime
just south of the city lies the dinano
wetlands National Park
the horses are grazing where there
should be water it is a sign that all is
not well
this heat wave comes after a hot dry
winter not just in Spain but across
Europe in fact last summer was Europe's
hottest ever and it's this dry parched
ground and lack of rainfall that's
starting to create real problems in this
country with Reservoir levels falling
and Farmers worried they can't water
their crops
drought driven by climate change says
the Spanish president has become a major
national concern
Field Guide Jose Gallen has watched the
land change around him and agrees they
worry more than for animal or planted of
course and worry more about the society
more about our way of life so we need to
think about this and it's a global
situation but in this area more close to
Africa
maybe that that impact will be higher
than in other places
kill a heat wave should start to ease by
the weekend but there is little real
relief in sight for southern Spain a
long hot summer awaits
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in Seville